(man) TONIGHT,
HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE NEXT BIG BUSINESS IDEA
WILL ENTER THE SHARK TANK
SEEKING THE FINANCIAL BACKING
TO MAKE THEIR DREAMS
COME TRUE.
I'M NOT A BUSINESSMAN.
WHAT ARE YOU THEN?
I'M A POLICE OFFICER.
CAN YOU PLEASE ARREST ROBERT?
AFTER ME AND YOU GET A DEAL,
YOUR WISH IS MY COMMAND,
THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY,
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT IDEA.
MY ORIGINAL PACKAGING
WAS A JAPANESE PROSTITUTE.
WHAT KIND OF A PRODUCT
WERE YOU SELLING?
I WOULD SAY
TO MOTHERS OF CHILDREN,
"LOOK, IF YOU DON'T BUY
MY SOFTWARE,
THEY'RE GONNA LIVE IN A GUTTER
WHEN THEY GET OLD."
THAT'S A WONDERFUL WAY
TO TALK TO CHILDREN, KEVIN.
BUT FIRST, THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
OBVIOUSLY,
YOU'RE NOT PREPARED,
AND YOU KNEW THAT.
YOU KNEW THAT COMING IN.
WELL, THAT'S WHERE WE DISAGREE.
WRONG ANSWER.
FEELING A LITTLE TENSE
IN THIS ROOM.
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK
ARE MICHAEL AND BABZ BARNETT
WITH A BUSINESS INSPIRED
BY THEIR CHILDREN.
♪♪
HI, MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BARNETT.
AND I'M HIS WIFE BABZ,
AND WE HAVE CREATED
A MAGICAL, WHIMSICAL PLACE
WHERE PARENTS CAN
BRING THEIR CHILDREN
FOR BONDING AND LEARNING.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS. HERE WE GO.
WE CAME UP WITH THE IDEA
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO,
WHEN I WAS TAKING
OUR TWO YOUNG CHILDREN
HERE, THERE AND EVERYWHERE FOR
DIFFERENT MOMMY AND ME CLASSES.
I NEEDED EVERYTHING
UNDER ONE ROOF,
SO THAT'S WHEN WE CAME UP
WITH THE IDEA FOR ROMP N' ROLL.
WELCOME TO ROMP N' ROLL!
(cheering)
ROMP N' ROLL IS A CHILDREN'S
ENRICHMENT CENTER.
WE OFFER OVER 20 DIFFERENT
CLASSES EVERY WEEK
IN THE AREAS OF GYM,
ART AND MUSIC.
OTHER PLACES WERE A LITTLE
UNKEMPT AND KINDA OUTDATED.
WE WANTED TO CREATE A PLACE
THAT WAS CLEAN, VIBRANT,
COLORFUL AND A PLACE
WHERE PARENTS COULD SPEND
GOOD, QUALITY ONE‐ON‐ONE TIME
WITH THEIR KIDS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TEN ROMP N' ROLL LOCATIONS,
FROM PENNSYLVANIA
TO PUERTO RICO,
AND WE'VE ALREADY DONE
$4 MILLION IN REVENUE
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
A ROMP N' ROLL
IN EVERY COMMUNITY
ACROSS THE WORLD,
AND WE NEED THE SHARKS' HELP
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL BARNETT.
THIS IS MY WIFE BABZ.
HI, SHARKS.
AND WE ARE THE FOUNDERS
OF ROMP N' ROLL.
WE ARE HERE TODAY SEEKING
AN INVESTMENT OF $300,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10%
OF THE EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
ROMP N' ROLL IS
A GROWING CHAIN
OF CHILDREN'S PLAY
AND LEARNING CENTERS
WITH MULTIPLE LOCATIONS.
ROMP N' ROLL‐‐A COLORFUL,
CREATIVE, WHIMSICAL ENVIRONMENT
THAT PARENTS CAN TAKE
THEIR CHILDREN
FOR GYM, ART AND MUSIC CLASSES
ALL UNDER ONE ROOF.
IN FACT, OUR TAGLINE
IS "NURTURE THE GENIUS,
UNLEASH THE GOOFBALL."
WE HAVE
SO MANY EXCITING CLASSES
THAT YOU CAN BRING YOUR CHILD,
EVERY WEEK TO ROMP N' ROLL,
FROM THE TIME THEY'RE
3 MONTHS TO 6 YEARS OLD,
AND NEVER TAKE
THE SAME CLASS TWICE.
BABZ, I'M SO EXCITED. I WANT
TO GO. IS THERE ADULT CLASSES?
WE GET THAT QUESTION A LOT.
(laughs)
THE FUN PART ABOUT IT IS,
YOU DO THESE CLASSES
WITH YOUR CHILDREN.
HOW DIFFERENT FROM GYMBOREE
IS‐‐IS YOUR CONCEPT?
WELL, HAVE ANY OF YOU BEEN
TO A GYMBOREE?
YES, I HAVE, MANY TIMES.
OKAY, WELL, CAN I GIVE YOU
AN ANALOGY?
YEAH.
GYMBOREE‐‐THE CASSETTE PLAYER,
ROMP N' ROLL‐‐THE MP3 PLAYER.
YES?
DO YOU HAVE SALES? HOW MANY,
UH, HOW MANY LOCATIONS?
YEAH, WE HAVE TEN LOCATIONS.
WE HAVE TWO CORPORATE STORES,
AND THEN WE STARTED FRANCHISING.
SO WE DO HAVE
EIGHT FRANCHISE LOCATIONS.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES LAST YEAR?
LAST YEAR WAS $1.2 MILLION.
AND WHAT WAS YOUR PROFIT
ON THAT?
UH, ABOUT 30%.
(O'Leary) DOES THAT INCLUDE‐‐
INCLUDING YOUR SALARIES?
NO.
(O'Leary)
HAVE YOU FIGURED OUT,
WHAT IS THE COST
OF ACQUIRING EACH CUSTOMER?
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
YOU EXIST.
RIGHT.
(O'Leary) WHAT DO YOU DO?
WE REACH OUT
TO A LOT OF THE MOMS' GROUPS,
BECAUSE THE MOMMY MARKETING
IS STRONGER
THAN ANY PRINT AD
OR ANY TV SHOW THAT YOU CAN DO.
MICHAEL, WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF YOUR SALES GO TO MARKETING?
ABOUT 1%.
THAT'S ALL?
DON'T YOU THINK, AS YOU EXPAND
BEYOND YOUR BASE OF VIRGINIA,
THAT THAT WOULD HAVE TO
GO UP SUBSTANTIALLY?
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S ADMIRABLE
WHAT YOU'VE DONE,
BUT WHAT BOTHERS ME
ABOUT THE BUSINESS MODEL‐‐
YOU'RE SPENDING 1% OF SALES
ON MARKETING.
I CAN'T POINT
TO ANY FRANCHISE MODEL
THAT IS SUPPORTED
BY 1% IN MARKETING.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE DOWNPLAYING
THE PASSION THAT PARENTS HAVE
FOR A QUALITY PROGRAM THAT
COMBINES EDUCATION AND PLAY.
NO, I‐I‐I BUY THAT. THERE'S‐‐
I‐‐LOOK, I USED TO SELL SOFTWARE
TO MOTHERS OF CHILDREN
SO THEY COULD LEARN HOW TO READ,
AND I'D SAY TO THEM, "LOOK,
IF YOU DON'T BUY MY SOFTWARE,
THEY'RE GONNA LIVE IN A GUTTER
WHEN THEY GET OLD."
WELL, THAT WAS A GREAT SALES
PITCH. BEAUTIFUL. BEAUTIFUL.
IT WORKS. WE SOLD A BILLION
DOLLARS OF IT, BARBARA,
LEARNING HOW TO PLAY
THOSE EMOTIONS.
THAT'S A WONDERFUL WAY
TO TALK TO CHILDREN, KEVIN.
I HAVE TO LOOK AT IT AS
AN INVESTOR, AND SAY TO MYSELF,
IS THAT REALLY GONNA WORK
IN THE LONG RUN?
THERE ARE
SOME TROUBLING SIGNS.
ON THE OTHER HAND,
THERE'S SOME AMAZING GROWTH.
I'M IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR BUSINESS,
BUT MY GUT TELLS ME
THE BUSINESS MODEL ISN'T BAKED,
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
I'M OUT.
UM, I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO BUILD A NATIONAL BRAND
VERY QUICKLY,
SO ON THAT BASIS, I‐I'M OUT.
(Robert)
BABZ, WHAT'S YOUR‐‐WHICH‐‐
CAN I SPEAK TO THAT?
ARE YOU‐‐
MAYBE CHANGE YOUR MIND?
I'M‐‐I'M STILL OUT.
I HAVE A 3 1/2 YEAR OLD
THAT I TAKE TO GYMBOREE CLASSES
TWICE A WEEK.
UNLUCKY FOR YOU... (chuckles)
THE ONE I USED TO GO TO
RECENTLY CLOSED,
AND NOW I HAVE TO WALK
AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT BLOCKS
IN NEW YORK CITY
TO GET HER TO THE NEXT ONE,
AND I DON'T BOTHER.
AND SO I'VE HAD
THE FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE
OF SEEING A FAILURE RECENTLY,
AND I CAN'T GET OVER
THAT HURDLE.
SADLY, I, TOO, MUST BE OUT.
BABZ, WHY NOT A DAY CARE?
BARBARA, I HAVE TO CO‐‐
I CAN'T STAND THAT YOU ARE
COMPARING, UH, YOUR EXPERIENCE
AT GYMBOREE TO ROMP N' ROLL.
THAT‐‐
I HATE THAT YOU'RE MAKING
A JUDGMENT ON OURS
BASED UPON THAT ONE CLOSING
IN MANHATTAN.
I DON'T THINK
YOU MADE IT CLEAR, THOUGH,
WHAT THE POINT OF DIFFERENCE IS,
REALLY, STILL, IN MY MIND.
MM‐HMM.
WELL...
CAN WE TRY AGAIN?
THE BIGGEST THING IS
THE VARIETY OF CLASSES.
AT ROMP N' ROLL, THEY DO 12
WEEKS, THEN THEY GO ON TO GYM,
THEN THEY GO ON
TO A PRINCESS CLASS,
TO AN ART CLASS.
WE CAN KEEP THEM COMING BACK
OVER AND OVER AND OVER.
AND WHAT'S NICE, IF THEY JUST
WANT TO STAY IN OUR GYM CLASS,
EVERY WEEK
IS A DIFFERENT THEME.
EVERY WEEK, THE EQUIPMENT
IS COMPLETELY SWITCHED AROUND.
BABZ, H‐HOW MANY, UH,
HOW MANY SHARKS ARE IN
AND HOW MANY SHARKS ARE OUT?
I THINK YOU'RE ALL STILL IN.
I THINK YOU'RE ALL
STILL INTERESTED. (laughs)
NO, NO, BUT ALL‐‐
ALL JOKING ASIDE.
THERE'S ONE THAT IS
STILL A POSSIBILITY.
I MEAN, THERE'S FOUR PEOPLE
THAT ARE CLEARLY OUT.
I'M IN, BUT ALL YOUR ENERGY
IS GOING THAT WAY.
I'M JUST CONFUSED.
WELL, WE WANTED
TO DEFEND OUR POINTS.
ROBERT, WE'LL STOP
DOING THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE HAVE SO MUCH PASSION
FOR OUR BUSINESS,
WE CAN'T STAND TO HAVE SOMEBODY
TELL US THAT THEY DON'T...
I RESPE‐‐I RES‐‐
I HAPPEN TO RESPECT SOMEBODY
THAT A NO IS A DEFINITE MAYBE.
(chuckles)
SO WHAT OTHER QUESTIONS
CAN WE ANSWER?
UM...
MAYBE‐‐MAYBE YOU'RE RIGHT,
DAYMOND. UH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
A GOOD ENTREPRENEUR NEVER TAKES
NO FOR AN ANSWER,
BUT A SMART BUSINESSMAN
KNOWS WHEN TO MOVE ON.
SO IT'S FEELING A LITTLE TENSE
IN THIS ROOM,
WHEN I‐‐(laughs)
YOU KNOW, I'LL TELL YOU WHY‐‐
BECAUSE VERY FEW PEOPLE
CAN COME IN HERE
AND TALK ABOUT MILLIONS IN SALES
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CASH FLOW.
I WAS ON THE VERGE
OF MAKING YOU AN OFFER,
AND YOU COMPLETELY DIVERTED
YOUR ENERGY AWAY.
SO NOW MY CONCERN IS, ARE YOU
GONNA STAY FOCUSED ENOUGH?
WE'VE LEFT TWO HIGH‐PAYING JOBS
IN CORPORATE AMERICA,
WE'VE SOLD OUR BEACH HOUSE
AND WE'VE INVESTED ALMOST ALL
OF OUR CAPITAL IN THIS COMPANY.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE A QUICK NO
WITHOUT PUSHING BACK,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE DON'T AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
ROBERT IS BABZ AND MICHAEL'S
LAST CHANCE TO MAKE A DEAL,
BUT THEIR FOCUS
ON KEEPING BARBARA IN
MAY HAVE BLOWN THEIR CHANCES.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE A QUICK NO
WITHOUT PUSHING BACK,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE DON'T AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
YOU HAVE ENOUGH
OF A REAL BUSINESS
THAT I'M GENUINELY INTERESTED.
HAVING SAID THAT,
I THINK THIS IS GONNA REQUIRE
MORE OF MY TIME.
BASED ON THE NUMBERS,
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $300,000
FOR 51% OF THE BUSINESS.
CAN WE TAKE A MOMENT?
CAN WE TAKE A MINUTE?
ALL RIGHT.
(Michael) THERE IS NO WAY
THAT WE'RE GONNA
GIVE THEM THE COMPANY FOR 50%.
OF COURSE NOT. NOT FOR THAT.
WE CAN LET THEM THINK THAT
FOR A FEW MINUTES. (laughs)
YEAH, EXACTLY.
I COULDN'T DISAGREE
WITH WHAT THEY SAID MORE.
WE ARE EXCELLENT MANAGERS, WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH CORPORATE AMERICA.
FOCUSED BEYOND‐‐I MEAN, I DON'T
KNOW WHERE HE GOT THAT FROM.
ALL RIGHT, SHOULD WE
TAKE ONE MORE SHOT...
LET'S TAKE ONE MORE SHOT.
AND COUNTER AT 20%?
ROBERT,
I MADE ALL OF MY MONEY
SELLING HOPE TO PARENTS
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS HAS SOME OF THAT MAGIC
IN IT. I TELL YOU WHAT.
I WOULD GO 50/50 WITH YOU
ON A CONTROL POSITION.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED MORE CASH
ANYWAYS.
I AM COMPLETELY OUT
IF IT'S NOT CONTROL.
YES, I'LL BRING YOU IN.
ALL RIGHT,
WE TALKED ABOUT IT,
AND, UM, I FEEL LIKE WE HAVEN'T
FULLY EXPLAINED OUR COMPANY‐‐
BABZ, BEFORE‐‐I DON'T MEAN
TO CUT YOU OFF,
BUT, UH, WHILE YOU WERE OUT,
THE SHARKS TALKED ABOUT IT.
AND THE GOOD NEWS IS,
KEVIN IS HAPPY TO COME IN,
SO OUR OFFER COMBINED IS
$300,000
FOR 51% OF THE BUSINESS,
BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY KEY TO ME,
TO MAINTAIN CONTROL.
WELL, AGAIN, I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU FULLY UNDERSTAND
OUR BUSINESS.
WAIT. DON'T SAY THAT.
I KNOW YOUR BUSINESS.
DO YOU KNOW ANYBODY ELSE
IN YOUR SPHERE OF CONTACTS
THAT'S EVER SOLD AN EDUCATIONAL
BUSINESS FOR OVER $3 BILLION?
DO YOU?
WE DO NOT.
(Robert) SO, BABZ, YOUR‐‐
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ONE
RIGHT HERE.
WE CAN ARGUE ABOUT THIS
ALL DAY LONG.
ARE THESE GUYS
GONNA GIVE YOU AN ANSWER?
WHAT WAS
YOUR ANSWER, BABZ?
(O'Leary) WHAT DO YOU SAY?
RESPECTFULLY, WE'D LIKE
TO COUNTEROFFER, UM, AT 20%.
51% OF OUR BUSINESS, UM,
AFTER WHAT WE'VE PUT INTO IT
AND WHERE WE ARE
AFTER FIVE YEARS,
I DON'T THINK
IS A FAIR OFFER.
WE ARE NOT WILLING
TO GIVE THAT UP.
SO YOUR‐‐YOUR COUNTEROFFER
IS WHAT?
20%.
FOR $300,000?
CORRECT.
SO YOU THINK THAT THE BUSINESS
IS WORTH $1.5 MILLION TODAY?
WE THINK IT'S WORTH $3 MILLION,
BUT WE'D LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU
AND‐‐
IT'S NOT WORTH $3 MILLION,
NOT IN TODAY'S WORLD.
WELL,
THAT'S WHERE WE DISAGREE.
THE RISK IS TOO HIGH.
I CAN'T SEE HOW
I'D GET MY MONEY BACK AT 20%.
I STICK TO MY ORIGINAL OFFER.
NO?
NO, THANK YOU.
NO, NOT EVEN CLOSE.
(Babz chuckles)
NOT EVEN MAYBE.
(O'Leary) YOU KNOW‐‐
WELL, I'M‐‐I'M OUT.
OVER TO YOU.
I'M VERY FRUSTRATED
WITH YOU GUYS, I GOTTA TELL YOU.
WHY?
I THINK YOU'RE TRYING
TO SELL THE FUTURE
IN A WAY THAT NO INVESTOR
WOULD PAY FOR.
THE WORLD'S CHANGED.
YOU CAN'T GET THAT LOAN
FROM A BANK,
OR YOU WOULD HAVE DONE IT.
WE BOTH KNOW THAT.
IT'S A MISSED OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU... AND FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
GOOD LUCK.
I LIKED IT A LOT.
I LIKED IT A LOT. I REALLY DID.
(Robert) THEY HAVE TO GO
TO THE BANKS.
IT WAS A GREAT BUSINESS.
THE VALUE WAS CRAZY.
WITH EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE
PUT INTO THIS COMPANY‐‐
FIVE YEARS
OF FULL‐TIME DEDICATION
AND THE FACT THAT WE'VE
ALREADY GOT TEN LOCATIONS‐‐
AND THEY THINK WE'RE ONLY
WORTH $600,000?
THEY'RE WAY OFF THE MARK.
IT'S INSANE.
MONTHS AGO,
WE WATCHED LORI LITE
SEAL A $250,000 DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN.
I THINK WE CAN WORK TOGETHER.
IS THAT A YES?
I ACCEPT YOUR DEAL.
IT'S A CRAZY DEAL...
IT'S NOT A CRAZY DEAL AT ALL.
BUT CRAZIER THINGS
HAVE HAPPENED. THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE WHAT SHE'S UP TO NOW.
♪♪
THIS IS A DREAM‐COME‐TRUE DAY
FOR ME.
I'M HERE AT BORDERS BOOKSTORE
TO DO A SIGNING AND A READING
OF ONE OF MY BEST‐SELLING BOOKS.
STRESS FREE KIDS
IS A LINE OF BOOKS AND CDs
DESIGNED TO HELP CHILDREN
DECREASE STRESS AND ANGER
WHILE PROMOTING
THEIR SELF‐ESTEEM.
"SHE PLACED HERSELF ACROSS
FROM THE DOLPHIN AND SAID,
'I BELIEVE IN MYSELF.'"
(children and Lori)
I BELIEVE IN MYSELF!
(Lori)
BUT THE MOST EXCITING NEWS
IS THAT MY TITLES HAVE BEEN
PICKED UP BY BORDERS
AND ARE GOING TO BE
IN THEIR STORES NATIONWIDE.
THIS IS
THE BEST BOOK EVER.
IT'S THE BEST BOOK EVER?
YEP.
THE FUTURE IS REALLY BRIGHT
FOR STRESS FREE KIDS.
WE ARE EXPANDING OUR BRAND,
WE ARE REACHING MORE CHILDREN
NOT ONLY IN AMERICA,
BUT GLOBALLY.
HI, HONEY.
I WOULD NOT HAVE GOTTEN
TO THIS PLACE
THIS FAR THIS FAST
WITHOUT "SHARK TANK."
♪♪
NEXT UP ARE MARIX STONE
AND NANCY TANCHEL
WITH A PRODUCT
DESIGNED TO LOOK COOL
WHILE KEEPING YOU SAFE.
HI. I'M MARIX STONE,
AND I'M THE CREATOR AND DESIGNER
OF HELLS BELLS HELMETS.
I'M DR. NANCY TANCHEL.
I'M THE C. E. O. OF THE COMPANY.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU
FOR AN INVESTMENT OF $500,000
FOR 20% OF OUR COMPANY.
WHEW!
FOR THE PAST 15 YEARS,
I'VE BEEN DESIGNING PRODUCTS
FOR THE CUSTOM MOTORCYCLE
INDUSTRY.
I DEVELOPED THE ENTIRE
THREE‐DIMENSIONAL PROCESS
THAT IS INCLUDED
AND ALL THE ARTISTRY
THAT MAKES THE HELLS BELLS
A SUCCESS.
ESSENTIALLY,
WHAT I REALLY DID, THOUGH,
WAS I TOOK A LEGALLY MANDATED
SAFETY HELMET.
I MADE IT STRONGER,
I MADE IT SAFER
AND I MADE IT 10,000 TIMES
MORE APPEALING,
BECAUSE OF ALL
THE THREE‐DIMENSIONAL GRAPHICS
THAT ACTUALLY EVOLVED
FROM THE SHELL. OKAY?
SO...
THE, UM...
WE, UH...
ONLY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WATCHING. TAKE YOUR TIME.
ALL RIGHT.
(chuckles) AND BASICALLY
WHAT HAPPENED IS,
UH, WE... I'M SO SORRY.
A NERVOUS BIKER.
I AM REALLY NERVOUS.
WELL, LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT‐‐
WE OWN A UTILITY PATENT
TO PLACE
THREE‐DIMENSIONAL DESIGNS
ON NOT ONLY MOTORCYCLE HELMETS,
BUT ANY KIND OF SPORTING HELMET.
DO YOU HAVE
ANY SALES RIGHT NOW?
YES, WE DO. WE ACTUALLY ARE
ON TRACK THIS YEAR TO BRING IN
$300,000 OF SALES
JUST FOR THE MOTORCYCLE HELMETS.
LET ME SEE THE ONE WITH THE FACE
ON IT, THAT ONE THAT HE'S...
IT'S THE ONLY HELMET OF ITS KIND
IN THE WORLD.
BRING ANOTHER ONE UP.
WELL,
THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE
AND THE REASON WE'RE SEEKING
AN INVESTMENT FROM Y'ALL
IS SO THAT WE CAN GET INTO
THE MASS PRODUCTION
OF THESE HELMETS.
THAT TAKES A BIG INVESTMENT.
DOCTOR,
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING...
(Nancy) YES, SIR.
ABOUT THE DESIGN
OF THESE THINGS.
TAKE ROBERT, FOR EXAMPLE.
HE'S SORT OF A, UH,
A‐A DANDY WEEKEND DRIVER.
IS HE GOING TO REALLY HAVE
THE MERCHANT OF DEATH
ON THE FRONT OF HIS HELMET?
YES, I WOULD.
WELL, YOU KNOW, THE DESIGNS
CAN BE WHATEVER PEOPLE WANT.
NANCY, LET'S GO‐‐CAN I GO
BACK TO ONE THING...
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT YOU SAID AND WE KIND OF
COMPLETELY MISSED OVER?
YOU OWN A PATENT.
A UTILITY PATENT.
YOU'RE THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT CAN PUT A 3‐D DESIGN
ON ANY HELMET?
(Daymond) ON ANY...
SPORTING HELMET?
(Nancy) ANY SPORTS HELMETS.
SO, MARIX, IF THAT'S TRUE‐‐
AND I GUESS I HAVE TO GIVE YOU
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT‐‐
I JUST THINK THAT
THAT'S AN UNBELIEVABLE ASSET.
WE'D LOVE FOR YOU
TO CHECK IT OUT.
(laughs)
WHAT DOES A REGULAR HELMET
SELL FOR?
$175.
THIS ONE?
WELL, HOW ABOUT‐‐
WHAT'S THE PROFIT?
THE PROFIT MARGIN IS OVER 50%,
WELL OVER 50%.
AND IF WE WERE TO MASS PRODUCE,
BRING OUR COST DOWN
EVEN A LITTLE BIT MORE,
IT WOULD EVEN BE MORE FAVORABLE.
LET'S GET DOWN TO
THE NUMBERS FOR A SECOND.
2009 SALES‐‐END OF THIS YEAR,
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'LL MAKE
IN REVENUE OFF THESE HELMETS
THIS YEAR?
UM... (makes whooshing noises)
IT'LL BE AROUND $175,000
MAYBE A LITTLE MORE THAN THAT.
GUYS, I THINK THE POTENTIAL
HERE IS TREMENDOUS,
BUT IT'S TOUGH FOR ME
TO WRITE A CHECK
FOR HALF A MILLION
ON THE POTENTIAL.
SO I'M GONNA BOW OUT NOW.
THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
I'M IN THE SAME BOAT.
IT'S TOO LARGE A STRETCH‐‐
THE OPTIMISM, THE EXCITEMENT,
I LIKE THE HELMET, I PUT IT ON‐‐
I WAKE UP TOMORROW MORNING
AND I SAY TO MYSELF,
"WHY DID I GIVE
THOSE GUYS $500,000
JUST BECAUSE
THEY WERE SMILING AT ME?"
I NEED A LOT MORE EVIDENCE
THAT THIS TRAJECTORY IS VALID,
SO FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THIS ISN'T MY CUP OF TEA,
SO I JUST WANNA... I'M OUT.
THERE'S REALLY NO QUESTION.
THIS IS GONNA BE A HUGE PRODUCT,
WHETHER WE LICENSE IT OUT OR...
THE ONLY QUESTION IS...
YES?
THE NUMBER YOU PUT ON IT,
DOCTOR.
I UNDERSTAND. I UNDERSTAND.
BUT, UM, YOU KNOW, AGAIN,
AS YOU GUYS
HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED,
THERE IS THIS PATENT INVOLVED,
AND THIS PATENT
IS EXCEPTIONALLY BROAD.
THERE'S A HUGE VALUE
TO THIS PATENT.
YOU'RE VALUATING THE COMPANY
AT $2.5 MILLION,
AND YOU ONLY HAVE $300,000
IN SALES.
TO GIVE YOU $500,000 IN CASH,
I WOULD BE CRAZY RIGHT NOW.
♪♪
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND OR ROBERT ARE THEIR
ONLY CHANCE TO MAKE A DEAL.
NANCY, DO YOU WANT
TO SELL A LOT OF HELMETS
OR DO YOU WANT
TO MANUFACTURE THEM?
WELL, WE WANT TO DOMINATE
THAT INDUSTRY.
BUT IF WE COULD STRUCTURE
A DEAL...
MM‐HMM.
WHERE WE LICENSE IT
TO SOMEBODY ELSE,
WE NEVER HAVE
TO MAKE A SINGLE ONE...
RIGHT.
AND YOU COLLECT
A PERCENTAGE OF A ROYALTY
OR WHATEVER THE CASE IS...
SURE.
ARE YOU MORE INTERESTED
IN DOING THAT
OR ARE YOU MORE INTERESTED...
WELL, WE WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT.
WE WANT YOUR EXPERTISE.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT I‐‐
I'LL DO‐‐I'LL DO FOR YOU.
YES?
NORMALLY I WOULD ASK
FOR 51% OR 70%
TO TAKE ON ALL THIS,
BUT WHAT I'LL DO FOR YOU IS,
I'LL GO 50/50 WITH YOU.
FOR 50% OF THE COMPANY,
I WILL GIVE YOU THE $500,000,
AND MY OBJECTIVE
AT THE END OF THE DAY
IS TO LICENSE THIS
TO A BUNCH OF COMPANIES.
CAN I ASK THIS‐‐
WILL IT‐‐WILL IT HAVE
THE SAME DETAIL
AND THE‐‐THE ARTISTIC
PROPERTIES?
WE WILL BE PARTNERS, AND WE WILL
MAKE THIS DECISION TOGETHER.
AND ALL THE ASPECTS THAT MAKE
THIS GREAT WILL NEED TO BE THERE
OR IT'S NOT WORTH IT FOR ME.
MARIX, JUST SO YOU KNOW
WHERE I STAND...
I'M GONNA BE OUT. HIS
OFFER IS BETTER THAN MINE.
I WAS GONNA OFFER YOU
$500,000 FOR 75%,
BUT HIS OFFER IS BETTER
AS A STARTING POINT.
THANK YOU.
SO, GUYS, WHAT DO YOU SAY?
WE'RE EXCITED TO GET
INTO BUSINESS WITH YOU.
WE THINK WE CAN WORK TOGETHER
AND BUILD
A BILLION‐DOLLAR BRAND.
WELL, IS THAT A YES?
YES.
YOU BETCHA.
IT'S A YES ON MY SIDE.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE EXCITED. BYE.
(Marix) THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BYE.
WE'VE MADE A GOOD DEAL. I THINK
DAYMOND IS THE RIGHT PERSON.
HE'S INVOLVED WITH
A GOOD HISTORY OF BRANDING
AND‐‐AND SALES, SO I THINK
HE'S GONNA WORK WITH US,
AND WE WILL‐‐WE'RE GONNA BUILD
A BILLION‐DOLLAR BRAND TOGETHER.
I MAY REGRET THAT ONE.
THAT WAS PRETTY COOL, DAYMOND.
I GOTTA ADMIT.
IT WAS SUCH A BIG ASK
WITH SO LITTLE REVENUE.
I'M SO MAD AT YOU,
I'M GONNA RIDE AWAY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, BARBARA?
YOU LOOK ADORABLE,
BUT HE LOOKS RIDICULOUS.
♪♪
NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS ALFONZO DOWE, SR.,
WHO'S COME UP
WITH AN ACCESSORY
FOR ONE
OF AMERICA'S FAVORITE HOBBIES.
HELLO, SHARK TEAM MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ALFONZO DOWE, SR.,
AND MY PRODUCT IS THE TWISTER
PORTABLE GOLF BALL CLEANER.
I'M HERE
FOR TWO REASONS TODAY‐‐
ONE, I'M LOOKING
FOR AN $85,000 INVESTMENT,
AND TWO, I'M LOOKING
FOR A BUSINESS PARTNER.
FOR THIS,
I'M OFFERING 40% EQUITY.
BEING A LONGTIME GOLFER,
ONE THING I'VE FOUND
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
IS GOLFERS LOVE TO PLAY
WITH A CLEAN GOLF BALL.
WHY? BECAUSE THEY PERFORM BETTER
AND THEY LAST A LOT LONGER.
GOLFERS CONTINUALLY TAKE
A WET TOWEL
AND PUT IT ON THEIR BAG
TO CLEAN THEIR GOLF BALLS
OUT ON THE COURSE.
SO I CAME UP WITH THE TWISTER
PORTABLE GOLF BALL CLEANER.
LET ME SHOW YOU WHAT I MEAN.
SO YOU'RE OUT ON THE GOLF COURSE
AND YOU SET UP AND YOU TAKE
A COUPLE MAGNIFICENT SHOTS.
VOILà! ONE OF 'EM LANDS
OUT ON THE GREEN.
YEAH, YOU'RE PSYCHED NOW,
BUT WHEN YOU GET UP THERE,
WHAT DO YOU ENCOUNTER?
YOU ENCOUNTER THIS HERE‐‐
A DIRTY GOLF BALL
THAT'S FILTHY.
NOW YOU KNOW IF YOU GO
TO TRY AND MAKE THIS PUTT,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA MAKE IT,
BECAUSE THAT'S GONNA CAUSE
YOUR BALL TO ROLL OFF‐LINE.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO?
GO RIGHT TO YOUR BAG, YOU UNCLIP
YOU PORTABLE GOLF BALL CLEANER
AND SIMPLY UNSCREW IT.
YOU TAKE THE BALL
AND YOU PUT IT
ON THE BOTTOM HALF
FOR THE BRISTLES.
YOU TAKE THE TOP HALF
AND YOU SCREW IT BACK DOWN.
YOU GIVE IT A LITTLE SHAKE
AND THEN YOU SIMPLY TWIST
YOUR TWISTER BACK AND FORTH.
THAT CLEANS IT.
ONCE YOU'RE DONE
DOING THE TWIST,
YOU SIMPLY UNSCREW IT
ONCE AGAIN
AND YOU TAKE OUT A GOLF BALL
THAT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S BRAND‐NEW AGAIN.
(Daymond) FANTASTIC IDEA.
IT LOOKS GREAT.
ALFONZO...
THEY CALL ME "FONZ,"
AND I WAS THE FONZ
BEFORE THE FONZ WAS THE FONZ.
(Barbara and Robert laugh)
SO, FONZ, HAVE YOU SOLD
ANY OF THESE?
YES, I'VE SOLD SOME.
I HAVE SOLD.
WHERE DO YOU SELL 'EM, ONLINE?
WELL, I DO SELL SOME ONLINE.
PEOPLE GO TO MY WEB SITE
AND ORDER 'EM.
BUT AT THE FLEA MARKET IS
WHERE I'VE SOLD THE BULK OF IT.
(O'Leary)
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
I'VE SOLD ABOUT A COUPLE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH.
I HAVEN'T SOLD A LOT
BECAUSE I'M NOT A BUSINESSMAN.
SO YOU'RE NOT A BUSINESSMAN.
WHAT ARE YOU THEN?
I'M A POLICE OFFICER.
YOU'RE AN OFFICER?
I'M AN EXPERT
IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT FIELD.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO USE
YOUR NIGHT STICK ON HIM
WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
I WAS JUST GONNA SAY,
CAN YOU PLEASE ARREST ROBERT?
JUST FOR THE HECK OF IT.
AFTER ME AND YOU GET A DEAL,
YOUR WISH IS MY COMMAND.
(sharks laugh)
FONZ, HOW MUCH IS IT?
$19.99‐‐UNDER $20.
(Barbara) WHOLESALE?
AND HOW MUCH DOES IT
COST YOU TO MAKE?
$6.
I GET PITCHED A LOT
OF KOOKY GOLF STUFF.
(Daymond) RIGHT.
IT IS REALLY WELL‐MADE.
I MEAN‐‐
IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S VERY FUNCTIONAL.
DO YOU HAVE IT AT ANY RETAILERS?
NO, I DON'T HAVE IT IN ANY.
WHY ISN'T IT?
MY TIME IS VERY LIMITED,
AND I KNEW THIS DAY WOULD COME
WHERE I COULD PRESENT THIS
BEFORE SOMEBODY LIKE YOU,
A BUSINESS PARTNER.
HEY, ALFONZO, I'VE SOLD
SOME GOLF PRODUCTS BEFORE...
MM‐HMM.
AND I LIKE TO SELL SOMETHING
THAT WILL IMPROVE MY SCORE.
RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT‐‐
CAN I OFFER YOU SOMETHING?
(Harrington) YEAH.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT
FROM A GOLFER'S STANDPOINT.
FONZ, EXACTLY.
THERE'S THE RUB.
OKAY.
YOUR MARKET, IN FACT,
IS NOT THE GOLFER.
LET ME TRY‐‐
I WANT TO EDUCATE YOU.
THERE ARE 68 MILLION GOLFERS
IN THE WORLD.
THERE ARE 68 BILLION LOVED ONES
WHO LOVE THAT GOLFER,
KNOW THAT THEY LOVE TO PLAY
GOLF. THEY GO OUT ALL THE TIME
AND BUY THEM NEW STUFF BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THEY LIKE GOLF.
FAIR ENOUGH.
IT'S TRUE. I'D BUY IT FOR
MY HUSBAND. HE'S A GOLF NUT.
THEY WILL SEE THIS AND SAY,
"THAT'S A GREAT PRESENT
FOR MY"‐‐
GUESS WHAT. THAT MEANS IT'S
A SEASONAL GOLF PRODUCT THEN.
SO YOU'RE GONNA SELL SOME
AT CHRISTMAS MAYBE...
NO, THERE'S‐‐
BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA
SELL 'EM YEAR‐ROUND.
THERE'S BIRTHDAYS,
THERE'S FATHER'S DAYS,
THERE'S GOLF OUTINGS,
GIVEAWAYS, CORPORATE LOGOS.
I'M OUT.
(Barbara) I'VE BEEN DRAGGED
TO A LOT OF CORPORATE
GOLF OUTINGS WITH MY HUSBAND.
I HATE EVERY
MINUTE OF GOLF, I MUST SAY,
SO I HAVE A BAD EYE ON THIS.
MM‐HMM.
BUT I SEE TONS OF
PROMOTIONAL STUFF GIVEN OUT.
(Daymond) YEAH.
NOW I SEE THIS AS A CORPORATE
PROMOTIONAL ITEM EASILY.
I‐I AGREE.
BARBARA, THAT'S A TCHOTCHKE.
IT'S A TCHOTCHKE,
BUT THEY'LL BUY A LOT OF THEM.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
HOWEVER, I HATE GOLF.
SO FOR THAT REASON ALONE,
I'M OUT.
FONZ, WHERE ARE YOU
A POLICE OFFICER? WHICH CITY?
I LIVE IN NEW JERSEY,
BUT I WORK IN DELAWARE.
SO PLEASE DON'T ARREST ME
FOR SPEEDING
WHEN I'M IN NEW JERSEY.
(laughs)
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS
A HOLE IN ONE. I'M OUT.
I HAVE ONE SIMPLE QUESTION‐‐
WHAT DO YOU WANT THE MONEY FOR?
INVENTORY.
YOU NEED SALES
BEFORE YOU BUY INVENTORY.
YOU NEED AN ORDER
FROM SOMEBODY.
YOU'D BE IN A BETTER SITUATION
IF SOMEBODY SAID,
"LOOK, FONZ.
HERE'S AN ORDER FOR 10,000,"
AND THEN IF YOU CAME IN HERE
AND SAID, "WELL, UNCLE KEVIN,
I'VE GOT A 10,000 ORDER I CAN'T
FINANCE," I'D BE ALL OVER IT.
MM‐HMM.
BECAUSE I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
I'M A SIMPLE GUY.
BUT I CAN'T,
SO FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
FONZ, I KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT THIS SPORT,
AND I HAVE TO LISTEN TO MY GUT
AND SAY THAT RESPECTFULLY,
I'M OUT.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME,
AND I REALLY VALUE IT.
(sharks) THANK YOU.
GOOD DAY.
FONZ, CAN I BUY ONE?
CAN YOU BUY ONE?
YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK‐‐
AND I'LL GIVE YOU
A SPECIAL PRICE‐‐$19.99.
(sharks laugh)
MAYBE HE'S A BETTER PARTNER
THAN YOU THINK.
ENGINEERING‐WISE,
IT'S FANTASTIC.
(Harrington) TOO WELL MADE.
I DON'T GET IT. I DON'T KNOW
WHY YOU'D HAUL THAT AROUND.
IT TAKES TOO LONG TO SCREW ON.
I KNOW I GOT A GREAT PRODUCT.
IT'S JUST THAT, YOU KNOW,
WHEN THE TYCOONS DON'T WANT
TO SPEND THEIR MONEY
ON SOMETHING,
THE TYCOONS DON'T SPEND
THEIR MONEY ON SOMETHING.
IT'S NOT THE END OF THE ROAD.
♪♪
MY NAME IS DORENE HUMASON.
I LIVE IN FOLSOM, CALIFORNIA,
AND MY COMPANY IS
THE CHEF IN BLACK.
FOR THE PAST 25 YEARS, I HAVE
WORKED IN THE FOOD INDUSTRY
AS A BUYER AND A FOOD SALES
REPRESENTATIVE.
OH, LOOK AT THESE.
THERE WAS ONE TIME
I WAS GOING TO PREPARE
ONE OF MY KIDS' FAVORITE DISHES,
AND COULD NOT FIND
THE INGREDIENTS AT THE STORE.
SO THAT GAVE ME THE INSIGHT
THAT THERE WAS A VOID,
AND THAT'S HOW MY PRODUCT
WAS CREATED.
BON APPéTIT!
I HAVE CREATED
WHAT I BELIEVE WILL BE A HIT
TO CONSUMERS AROUND THE WORLD.
I REALLY NEED THE SHARKS
TO INVEST IN MY COMPANY
SO I CAN BRING IT
TO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
AND CONTINUE TO SHARE
THIS DELICIOUS PRODUCT.
THANKS, MOM.
♪♪
HI. I'M DORENE HUMASON,
PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF
THE CHEF IN BLACK INCORPORATED.
I'M REQUESTING
A $50,000 INVESTMENT
AND IN RETURN, I'M OFFERING
A 10% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
MY PRODUCT IS
JADEN CHINESE SALAD DRESSING
AND SEASONING MIX,
WHICH IS A PERFECT BLEND
OF ALL‐NATURAL SPICES
AND SEASONINGS
THAT ALLOWS THE HOME COOK
TO MAKE FRESH
CHINESE SALAD DRESSING AND DIPS.
BROOKE WILL NOW PASS OUT
SAMPLES TO EACH OF YOU
OF THE JADEN
CHINESE SALAD DRESSING.
I WAS ON A SEARCH
FOR THE PERFECT CHINESE SALAD
DRESSING AND HAD NO SUCCESS.
SO I TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DEVELOP A PRODUCT
THAT ADDRESSES IT.
MMM.
THIS IS A SINGLE PRODUCT?
JUST THAT ONE?
RIGHT NOW. I CURRENTLY HAVE
1,300 GROCERY STORES.
SO IT IS ON THE SHELF NEXT TO
THE DRY SALAD DRESSING PACKETS.
SO, DORENE, IS BROOKE
YOUR DAUGHTER, BY THE WAY?
YES, SHE IS.
YEAH.
SHE'S MY BABY.
YOU LOOK LIKE SISTERS.
OH, I LOVE YOU.
UM, H‐HERE'S MY CHALLENGE
WITH FOOD‐‐
I USED TO KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT THE FOOD BUSINESS,
AND THEN I MADE AN INVESTMENT
IN IT.
AND I'VE LEARNED
THAT THERE ARE MILLIONS
OF SALAD DRESSINGS,
BARBECUE SAUCES...
AND ALL KINDS
OF OTHER FOOD STUFF.
AND INEVITABLY,
IT ALL COMES DOWN
TO MARKET SHARE
ON A SHELF IN A STORE.
TELL ME YOUR PLAN‐‐HOW YOU'RE
GONNA GET THIS NATIONALLY
AND WE'RE GONNA SELL
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THAT IS EXACTLY, UM,
A VERY LEGITIMATE CONCERN,
AND BEING IN THE BUSINESS
FOR 27 YEARS, I KNOW THAT.
AND FOR ME TO QUIT MY JOB
AND TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS
AT THIS STAGE IN MY LIFE,
I NEEDED TO BE SURE
MY RISKS WERE LIMITED.
BUT I HAVE A PRODUCT
THAT IS VERY POPULAR.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE 1,300
STORES YOU'RE IN ALREADY.
CAN YOU TURN THAT
INTO DOLLARS TO ME?
'CAUSE THAT'S ALL I CARE ABOUT.
MY‐‐MY FIRST YEAR,
I HAD 450 STORES,
AND MY SALES WERE,
UM, $78,000.
AND WHAT ARE THEY THIS YEAR?
UM, CURRENTLY I'M AT $41,000,
BUT I HAD A HUGE LEARNING CURVE
ON MY PACKAGING.
I HAD TO PULL OLD PACKAGING OFF
AND PUT NEW PACKAGING ON.
WHY?
UM, MY ORIGINAL PACKAGING
WAS OFFENSIVE.
UH, I DIDN'T KNOW IT.
IT HAD HIS FACE ON IT?
IT‐‐IT‐‐IT WAS‐‐IT WAS
A JAPANESE PROSTITUTE.
WHAT KIND OF A PRODUCT
WERE YOU SELLING?
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
I WAS LOOKING FOR A PACKAGE
THAT WAS VERY INTERESTING,
AND SINCE I WAS A LITTLE
IGNORANT ON CULTURAL ART,
I HIRED A CHINESE ART EXPERT,
AND SHE E‐MAILED ME AND SAID,
"IT IS A JAPANESE PROSTITUTE
AND VERY OFFENSIVE."
SO I HAD TO STOP MY PROJECT...
(speaks indistinctly)
SO THE WHOLE IDEA OF
HOOKER ON THE BOX DIDN'T SELL.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WELL, IT DEPENDS
ON WHO YOU'RE TALKING TO.
YEAH, BUT ISN'T THAT
PART OF THE PROBLEM?
LEAVE THE HOOKER ASIDE
FOR A SECOND.
IS THIS A RUB?
IS THIS A SALAD DRESSING?
IS IT A FLAVORING, SEASONING?
AND THOSE ARE ALL DIFFERENT
POSITIONS IN THE GROCERY STORE.
TO START, I WANTED
TO DO THE DRY SALAD DRESSING
FOR THE REASON‐‐
IT WAS A LOW START‐UP COST
AND THERE'S NO COMPETITION.
DORENE, YOU HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF A MIXED MESSAGE,
AS I'M SEEING IT.
I SEE CHEF IN BLACK
AND I SEE JADEN.
UH, WHERE IS YOUR FOCUS
ON BUILDING THE BRAND HERE?
THE BRAND IS
THE CHEF IN BLACK.
WHY NOT CALL
THE COMPANY JADEN?
BECAUSE I'M GONNA HAVE
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
I HAVE A MEXICAN CAESAR
I'M WORKING ON.
I HAVE SOME VERY UNIQUE THINGS
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE...
SO WHAT ARE YOU‐‐
A WHOLE BRAND.
WHAT ARE YOU PROMOTING THEN‐‐
THE JADEN NAME
OR THE CHEF IN BLACK NAME?
THE CHEF IN BLACK
IS MY COMPANY.
(O'Leary) JADEN'S THE PRODUCT.
CHEF IN BLACK'S THE COMPANY.
IF YOU HAD A FOCUS
OF‐‐OF ONE BRAND, ONE PRODUCT,
AND YOU‐‐AND YOU BUILT
THAT BRAND,
AND THEN YOU STARTED LAUNCHING
SOME OF THESE OTHER PRODUCTS,
I COULD SEE MAYBE MAKING
AN INVESTMENT IN THAT KIND
OF A BUSINESS CONCEPT, BUT IT'S
JUST TOO CONFUSING FOR ME,
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH,
BUT I'M OUT.
I THINK KEVIN REALLY HIT‐‐
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO DEVELOP
THE ONE PRODUCT
AND‐‐AND GO NATIONWIDE
WITH IT.
BUT I'M OUT. THANK YOU.
DORENE, I ACTUALLY CONSULT
FOR SEVERAL FOOD COMPANIES,
AND I KNOW HOW HARD THIS IS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE DOING REALLY WELL,
BUT I'M JUST A LITTLE AFRAID OF
THIS BUSINESS AT THE MOMENT,
SO I'M OUT.
DORENE, IF THIS WAS GOING TO BE
A BIG CATEGORY,
DON'T YOU THINK A LARGE FOOD
MANUFACTURING BRANDED COMPANY
WOULD CRUSH YOU
LIKE A COCKROACH?
IT WOULD BE A SLAUGHTER FEST
FOR AN INVESTOR.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT,
'CAUSE I'M GONNA TELL YOU,
EVERY TIME THERE'S INNOVATION,
IT RARELY COMES
FROM THE BIG GUY.
THE LITTLE GUY HAS ALWAYS GOT
THE CORNER ON INNOVATION.
BUT IT'S A FLAVOR.
IT'S ONE FLAVOR.
IF I REALLY WANTED TO EMULATE
WHAT YOU'VE GOT IN THERE,
I COULD HIRE SOME GUYS
TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU MADE IT.
I SPENT SIX MONTHS GOING
TO ASIAN GROCERY STORES,
COMING UP WITH A RECIPE
THAT IS SO COMPLEX
THAT THEY WON'T
EVER BE ABLE TO COPY IT.
IT'LL NEVER BE
AS GOOD AS THIS.
I'M OUT.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DORENE ONLY HAS ONE CHANCE LEFT
TO MAKE A DEAL.
YOU KNOW, I'M SCARED TO DEATH
OF THE FOOD CATEGORY,
BECAUSE THE DEATH RATE
IS SO HIGH.
BUT YOU HAD
ALL THE RIGHT ANSWERS.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE COME
HERE AND MAKE GREAT PITCHES,
BUT WHEN YOU START ASKING
THE QUESTIONS,
THE WHOLE THING FALLS APART.
YOU HAVEN'T ALLOWED A CRACK
IN YOUR ANSWERS YET.
OH, THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO MAKE AN OFFER
FOR YOUR $50,000
FOR 40% OF YOUR BUSINESS.
40%.
BUT I'D HAVE TO KNOW THAT YOU
ARE COMMITTED TO THE FACT
THAT YOU HAVE CONFUSED BRANDING.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO PICK ONE,
AND YOU'D HAVE TO BE COMMITTED
TO JUST SELLING THAT DRY SALAD
DRESSING FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
BECAUSE WHAT FRIGHTENS ME
IS YOU'RE MOVING TOO FAST
WITH TOO MANY THINGS,
AND THAT'S USUALLY
A FORMULA FOR DISASTER
IN ANY YOUNG BUSINESS.
AND IF YOU'RE WILLING TO WORK
ON THOSE TERMS,
I'D BE VERY HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
AS MY PARTNER.
(clicks tongue)
WE HAVE INVESTED $300,000
IN THE COMPANY,
AND THIS RECIPE IS SO UNIQUE.
I SPENT‐‐
SOUNDS LIKE A "NO"
COMING DOWN THE TRACK.
♪♪
BARBARA HAS OFFERED DORENE
$50,000,
BUT FOR 40% OF HER COMPANY.
WE HAVE INVESTED $300,000
IN THE COMPANY,
AND THIS RECIPE IS SO UNIQUE.
I SPENT‐‐
SOUNDS LIKE A "NO"
COMING DOWN THE TRACK.
I‐I'D LIKE TO SEE
IF YOU'D GO TO 35%?
PARDON ME?
35% EQUITY.
AND, UH, I WILL DO
ALL OF THE‐‐
THE CHANGES THAT I NEED TO DO.
THAT'S ONE THING
YOU'LL FIND ABOUT ME
IS I'M A‐‐I'M VERY COMPLIANT.
AND, UH, WOULD 35% WORK?
I'M GONNA NEED MORE SALAD.
DORENE...
WE'VE GOT A DEAL.
(Robert) WHOO!
(Daymond) ALL RIGHT!
(Dorene) THANK YOU.
THAT WAS TENSE.
OH, I'M SO EXCITED.
WHOA. (laughs)
WOW! GOOD JOB.
OH! YAHOO!
THANK YOU. SEE, YOU'LL NEVER
BE ABLE TO COPY THAT, KEVIN.
(Barbara) I SUDDENLY LOVE
THE FOOD BUSINESS.
THANK YOU, DORENE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE BEST FOOD OPERATOR
WE'VE SEEN ON THIS SHOW.
YEAH. THE BEST‐TASTING DRESSING
I'VE HAD IN THIS CATEGORY.
WELL, LOOK AT YOU. MY, GOSH.
I'M LOVING IT.
SHE KNOWS HER STUFF, AND THERE'S
NO REPLACEMENT FOR THAT.
(Daymond) SHE'S A GOOD LADY.
(Robert) SHE DESERVES SUCCESS.
(Barbara) SHE'LL GET IT.
(Dorene) WORDS CAN'T EXPRESS
HOW EXCITED I AM.
TO GET THE SUPPORT OF THE SHARKS
IS JUST BEYOND
MY WILDEST DREAMS!
I CAN'T WAIT TO WORK
WITH BARBARA.
♪♪
MY NAME IS ANDY SPERRY,
I LIVE IN FRANKLIN, TENNESSEE,
AND MY BUSINESS IS INKFLIP.
MY PRODUCT WILL SIMPLIFY LIFE
FOR ANYONE
WHO USES A COMPUTER PRINTER.
INKFLIP CUSTOMERS SAVE MONEY,
SAVE TIME AND DO SOMETHING GREAT
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S LIKE ONLINE MOVIE RENTAL
FOR YOUR PRINTER.
WHEN I WAS IN CORPORATE AMERICA,
I REALIZED THAT THE ONLY WAY
I WAS EVER REALLY GONNA
GET AHEAD FINANCIALLY
WAS IF I BECAME MY OWN BOSS.
AS I'M SURE A LOT OF PEOPLE
CAN RELATE TO,
MY WIFE AND I HAVE DEALT WITH
SOME DIFFICULT FINANCIAL TIMES,
AND WE REALIZED
THAT TOGETHER AS A TEAM,
WE NEEDED TO MAKE GETTING OUT OF
DEBT A PRIORITY FOR OURSELVES
AND FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR KIDS.
I SIMPLY NEED TO GET THE WORD
OUT ABOUT THE INKFLIP SERVICE,
AND I BELIEVE
PEOPLE ARE GONNA LOVE IT.
♪♪
HI. MY NAME IS ANDY SPERRY.
I AM HERE TODAY SEEKING
A $150,000 INVESTMENT
IN RETURN FOR A 20% EQUITY
POSITION IN MY COMPANY INKFLIP.
ABOUT A YEAR AGO,
I WAS IN THE PROCESS OF PUTTING
THE FINAL TOUCHES ON THE BIGGEST
PRESENTATION OF MY LIFE‐‐
UH, I WAS PRINTING THE HANDOUTS
FOR THE MEETING.
UH, THIS WAS LATE AT NIGHT.
THE MEETING WAS
EARLY THE NEXT MORNING‐‐
UH, WHEN I CAME ACROSS
A SITUATION
THAT MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
CAN RELATE TO‐‐
MY PRINTER WAS OUT OF INK.
INKFLIP CUSTOMERS ALWAYS HAVE
SPARE OR BACKUP CARTRIDGES
ON HAND
IN INDIVIDUALLY PACKAGED BOXES.
THE NEXT TIME THEY RUN DRY,
THEY TAKE THE INKFLIP FULL,
PUT IT IN THEIR PRINTER,
TAKE THE EMPTY,
PUT IT BACK IN THE PREPAID,
PREADDRESSED INKFLIP BOX.
THAT SIMPLY GOES
IN THE OUTGOING MAIL.
WHEN IT ARRIVES AT INKFLIP,
WE'RE GONNA REFILL
THAT CARTRIDGE
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
SEND IT BACK TO THEM
SO THAT NEXT TIME THEY RUN DRY,
THEY'VE ALREADY GOT A SPARE.
ANDY, HOW DO I GET
MY FIRST INKFLIP CARTRIDGE?
BECAUSE I JUST KNOW THAT OUR
FRIENDLY PRINTER MANUFACTURER
IS GONNA HAVE YOU ASSASSINATED.
(chuckles) UH, WE'RE‐‐
WE'RE AN ONLINE COMPANY,
SO YOU'RE COMING TO OUR PORTAL,
AND WE ARE SENDING YOU
THAT FIRST CARTRIDGE
SO THAT YOU HAVE IT IN STOCK,
SO THAT THE FIRST TIME
YOU RUN DRY,
THEN YOU ARE IN THE LOOP.
BUT WHY WOULD THE MANUFACTURER
LET YOU TAKE AWAY THEIR REVENUE?
THEY CAN'T REQUIRE YOU
TO USE THEIR PRODUCTS.
THE REFILL PRINTER CARTRIDGE
BUSINESS IS HUGE.
IT'S‐‐IT'S A‐‐IT'S
A $10‐BILLION BUSINESS.
DO YOU HAVE SALES?
UH, YES. NOW THIS IS A COMPANY
THAT'S ONLY BEEN UP AND GOING
FOR ABOUT 6 MONTHS,
SO I HAVE $10,000 IN REVENUE.
(chuckles)
OKAY, LET'S HAVE
A VERY QUICK MATH LESSON‐‐
WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT VERY EASY‐‐
JUST TO FIGURE OUT
IF YOU'LL EVER MAKE ANY MONEY,
OKAY?
RIGHT ON.
HOW MANY TIMES DOES
THE AVERAGE CUSTOMER,
PER YEAR, SEND BACK
HIS INKFLIP BOX?
INDUSTRY STATISTICS SAY
THE AVERAGE CUSTOMER
IS GONNA USE
SEVEN CARTRIDGES A YEAR.
HOW MUCH MONEY PER TRIP
DO WE MAKE AT INKFLIP?
$8 TO $10.
OKAY, LET'S SAY $10, OKAY?
THAT MEANS EACH CUSTOMER'S
GONNA MAKE US $70 A YEAR.
CORRECT.
NOW HERE'S THE KILLER QUESTION,
ANDY‐‐
WHAT IS THE COST
OF ACQUIRING THAT CUSTOMER?
THAT IS THE KILLER QUESTION,
AND I'LL BE HONEST.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER
TO THAT, AND‐‐AND‐‐
WRONG ANSWER.
I'M‐‐I‐‐BUT I'M HERE
FOR THE EXPERTISE...
WRONG ANSWER.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE
YOU GUYS HAVE THAT.
LIGHTNING BOLT FROM SKY
COMING DOWN AT YOU.
YOUR BUSINESS MODEL IS
PREDICATED ON GETTING CUSTOMERS,
BUT YOU DON'T KNOW THE COST
OF GETTING THOSE CUSTOMERS.
THE ONE NUMBER
YOU NEEDED HERE TODAY
WAS THE COST
OF ACQUIRING A CUSTOMER.
NOW YOU'VE BEEN HONEST.
YOU SAID YOU DON'T KNOW.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
THAT'S THE WRONG ANSWER.
RIGHT. BUT I'M‐‐I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I NEED MONEY
TO SPEND ON MARKETING
AND ADVERTISING.
HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE YOU PUT
INTO IT SO FAR, ANDY?
I PERSONALLY HAVE ABOUT
$50,000 INTO IT.
BUT, ANDY, THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU'RE SAYING, "MR. SHARK,
"GIVE ME $150,000 SO I CAN GO
FIND OUT THE ANSWER
TO THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION
IN MY LIFE."
NOW WHAT HAPPENS
IF THE ANSWER COMES OUT,
AND IT'S $250
TO ACQUIRE THE CUSTOMER?
(laughs) WELL, I MEAN,
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE ON THAT SIDE
OF THE TABLE, AND YOU‐‐YOU HAVE
THE OPTION TO TAKE THE RISK
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
THE RISK THAT I DON'T HAVE.
ANDY, HERE'S THE THING‐‐
I LIKE TO TAKE RISKS.
THAT'S HOW I MAKE MONEY.
BUT THEY'RE CALCULATED RISKS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WITHOUT KNOWING
THE ANSWER TO THAT NUMBER‐‐
THE ONLY NUMBER THAT MATTERS‐‐
YOU'RE A CRAPSHOOT.
I'M ROLLING THE DICE.
THE NUMBER‐‐
WHEN YOU LEAVE HERE, IT'LL BE
BURNED ON YOUR HEINIE.
YOU SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
THAT NUMBER.
THAT'S WHY I'M OUT.
I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE
ENOUGH EDUCATION.
THERE'S NO PROPRIETARY
PRODUCTS IN HERE. I'M OUT.
ANDY, IT'S TOO RISKY FOR ME,
SO I'M OUT.
DON'T YOU THINK
YOU SHOULD START A BUSINESS,
TEST THE MARKET
AND THEN GO OUT
AND TRY TO EXPAND?
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IT
COMPLETELY BACKWARDS.
YOU'RE GONNA USE MY MONEY
TO TEST THE MARKET? IT'S CRAZY.
ANDY, GOOD GUY,
MAYBE NAIVE GUY.
I DON'T KNOW.
BAD PLAN. I'M OUT.
I'M THINKING OF $150,000,
AND HOW I HAD TO KILL MYSELF
TO GET MY HANDS ON IT,
AND I COULDN'T IMAGINE
ME GIVING YOU THAT MONEY
JUST TO SEE
IF THIS IDEA MIGHT WORK.
YOU HAVE NOT DONE YOUR HOMEWORK.
AND I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, ALL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN HERE TODAY,
ANDY?
WELL, I‐I CERTAINLY
LEARNED, UM...
BY THE WAY, I KNEW THAT WAS
MY BIGGEST PROBLEM, COMING IN.
WHAT I LEARNED IS THAT THE THING
THAT'S IN THE BACK OF YOUR HEAD
THAT'S SAYING "DON'T GO
IN WITHOUT THIS" IS
IS THE THING THAT YOU NEED TO
WORK ON MOST. AND HONESTLY...
BINGO!
IF I DIDN'T HAVE MY FAMILY
AT A POINT WHERE, YOU KNOW,
WE JUST CAN'T GO
ANY FURTHER WITH THIS,
THEN I WOULD HAVE
THAT ANSWER FOR YOU.
BUT I WASN'T WILLING TO‐‐TO GO
ANY DEEPER FINANCIALLY,
UH, WHERE MY FAMILY
IS CONCERNED.
SMART MOVE.
SO...
BUT GO OUT, WORK HARD.
I LIKE THE FACT
YOU'RE NOT RISKING YOUR FAMILY.
BUT YOU CAN GET THERE.
YOU KNOW, YOU‐‐YOU CAN ALWAYS
GO DOWN THE ROAD IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO MAKE THE JOURNEY.
IT JUST MIGHT BE
A LITTLE LONGER.
RIGHT. THANK YOU.
(Robert) GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL.
WELL, THANKS FOR NOT BEING
SO MEAN ON THIS GUY TODAY.
I WASN'T MEAN TO HIM.
I WAS JUST HONEST.
NO, YOU WEREN'T.
I'M‐‐I'M CONGRATULATING YOU.
BARBARA, FROM NOW ON,
I WISH YOU TO ADDRESS ME
AS THE "MERCHANT OF TRUTH."
OH.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE, FOLKS‐‐
IF YOU'RE GONNA MEET
WITH THE SHARKS,
YOU BETTER DO YOUR HOMEWORK.
♪♪
(man) ♪ THE BEST THINGS
IN LIFE ARE FREE ♪
♪ BUT THAT AIN'T REALLY
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME ♪
♪ I NEED MONEY ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT I WANT ♪
♪ WHAT I WANT ♪